well we begin in Turkey where the
Parliament is expected to vote in the
next viewers on a government motion to
deploy troops to Libya Ankara supports
the un-backed government in Tripoli
that's fighting warlord Holy Fathers
forces they launched an offensive to
capture the capital last April turkey
says its troops will protect its rights
in the Mediterranean and its interests
in Libya Ankara and Tripoli recently
signed deals on military cooperation and
maritime boundaries meanwhile Greece
Israel and Cyprus are also about to sign
off on an agreement to transport gas
from the eastern Mediterranean to Europe
that's at odds with turkeys deal with
Libya to extract gas from the sea well
Mahmoud Abdul Wahid is standing by for
us in Libya's capital Tripoli but first
let's head straight to Ankara where
Mohammed's adult is live Mohammad first
of all is this proposal likely to pass
the Turkish Parliament yes very likely
hala
the ruling party members here in the
parliament in Ankara are quite confident
that they will be able to pass this bill
without much effort because together
with a CHP party which is allowed to
present other ones a critique a party
they are they are confident that they
will be able to pass is only the OEE
party which is an opposition party with
36 members in Parliament which is so far
or posed outrightly to it but they are
saying that is not their final decision
and they are right now meeting in one of
the conference rooms trying to figure
out how to vote so yes it's expected to
pass and we're seeing some sort of an
accelerated process with Parliament
coming out of recess to discuss this
turkey is really itching to deploy its
troops to Libya and Mohammed just
reminds us a few words what is Turkey's
interest in Libya
what official lines the Ark that Turkey
is on the right side of history
supporting a government that is
recognized by the United Nations and not
as they say a couplet a meaning after
general after who has been supported
they say by some Gulf European and
countries in of Africa such as Egypt but
the real deal here is Turkey is trying
to protect that maritime boundary
agreement it's signed with the DNA
government in Libya in Tripoli the one
that's recognized by the United Nations
of course these maritime boundary
agreement gives Turkey not only greater
territorial claims on the Mediterranean
but also increases its influence there
at a time other countries like Cyprus
Greece Israel and Egypt trying not only
to extract gas but ship it to Europe
through the Mediterranean and Turkey had
been cornered by that agreement between
those countries and had been left out
sort of and this has now sort of given
it greater influence and it is trying to
protect the agreement knowing very well
that if half there takes over Tripoli
and get into the capital and in power
then that bill will be obsolete and that
is what is it is really trying to avoid
okay Mohammed's auto lifers in Ankara
for now thank you let's cross over to
Tripoli now where Muhammad Abdul Waris
is standing by mahmoud if this trip
deployment is approved how does this
change the military dynamic the balance
of power in Libya will her it will
definitely change the balance of power
on the ground as you know today that all
eyes in Libya are on Turkey to see
what's going to come out of the Turkish
Parliament session today as you know how
that
turkey seems to be the only major
military supporter of the UN recognized
government forces in the west of Libya
on the country on the other hand after
scamp have been supported by regional
and international powers several
countries have been really rallying
behind Hector as you know hala including
Russia the United Arab Emirates Egypt
and France and today military commanders
in southern Tripoli say that they have
been noticing that Hefner's also have
been accelerating the fighting recently
in an attempt to proceed towards the
capital city center
it seemed that after sources are trying
to achieve an advancement on the ground
before turkey decides to send troops to
Libya as you know that because this is
going to definitely change the balance
of power on the ground in favor of the
government forces also have those forces
seem to be trying to gain more ground
before Berlin meeting as you know that
Berlin meeting is supposed to be held in
cooperation with the countries regional
and international countries concerned
with the Libyan issue so it seems that
half those forces are trying to gain
more ground in this battle to control
Tripoli so that they can have a better
opportunity on the negotiating table in
Berlin in all cases the government
forces say that if half those forces do
not have any legal standing recruiting
Russian mercenaries from the Vagner
company then the legitimate government
which is the government of national
court has the right to to bring foreign
troops and code in terms of the military
agreement with another legitimate
government which is the Turkish
government hala okay for now Mahmoud
Abdul Ahad joining us from Tripoli thank
you
let's stay with this we're joined there
by Sammy Hamdi he's the editor in chief
of the international interest
and joins us now from London good to
have you with us here on al-jazeera
there are so many people weighing in on
Libya let's focus specifically on Turkey
why do you think they're getting
involved and backing the GNA in
particular because given the advance of
half those forces and the support that
hafta has I mean this is something of a
gamble is it not first of all we have to
remember that Turkey's actually been
supporting the GNA in repelling after
for the last eight months you'll
remember that in the first few weeks of
the conflict after sees Turkish hostages
and complained that Turkish drones were
halting his advance into Tripoli it's
only because the Russians support over
the last three months that we've seen
after actually make advances prior to
this it was a stalemate but Turkey has
another reason to get involved anybody
who brings out a map of the
Mediterranean Sea will see that there is
a choke hold forming you'll see to the
northwest there is Greece to the west
there is a Cyprus and to the South there
is Egypt in other words it's forming
this block on Turkish maritime interests
if half their tastes control of Tripoli
half that is backed by the UAE and by
Egypt both of them are antagonistic
towards Turkey in other words it
completes this choke hold this is why
Libya is as important to Turkey as Syria
and this is why we see that for Turkey
it's not about Sarah it's not about the
government of national Accord it's not
about rescuing this Libyan government
even though that is what it wants to do
at this moment in time it doesn't it's
it's ready to accept any government in
Libya that is formed by the people or
comes out to negotiations as long as
half there is not the dominant force as
long as the UAE is not the prime
influence as long as Egypt is not the
primary fluence as long as France which
has for many years prevented this
development of Turkish relations with
the EU as long as France is not the
primary power and we see from this
agreement that's been signed between
Greece Egypt and Cyprus that Turkish
fears are not unfounded they have reason
to fear how can a country such as Turkey
be excluded from an agreement in the
Mediterranean Sea the fact that it has
been excluded excluded shows that there
is a targeted campaign from Egypt from
Israel and from Greece to isolate Turkey
to prevent it from having that access to
the Mediterranean the
is all according to the Turkish
perspective and this is why we see that
they are ready to deploy troops in Libya
in order to prevent that chokehold from
actually coming into practice and so
what implications do you think this move
has for the developments in the East
Mediterranean because there are several
interests they're trying to exploit
natural gas reserves but also these
pipelines getting energy from Israel and
the eastern Mediterranean into Europe
what implications does this move by
Turkey potentially have I think we have
to first and foremost remember that for
turkey and indeed the attitudes that the
cut coming out of Ankara we have to
remember that they have felt that they
have had to force their opinion the
force themselves on everybody else in
order to get them to listen in Syria and
again wanted a safe zone for many many
years and he was ignored by Washington
he was ignored by the EU and he was even
ignored by Russia and Iran only when he
threatened to enter unilaterally did the
Americans back down and did Russia back
down and everybody else and say ok and
again now we understand you have
security issues we'll give you the safe
zone in other words Turkey is saying I
have I have cried out for ages and said
to you guys let's cooperate on the
Mediterranean let's share this guest
let's talk about exploration rights
let's sit at the table and negotiate
everybody's been in been ignoring Turkey
because it's becoming a more expensive
power it's becoming a strong country
it's no longer a 30 category country
it's no longer on a par with Saudi
Arabia and Egypt it has surpassed these
countries and become a country that can
actually impose its will on the
international community and input and
sit at the negotiating table with the
likes of Russia with the likes of the US
so when we talk about the impact of the
eastern Mediterranean the choice is not
necessarily for Turkey to take the
choices on the country is to say look do
we bring turkey to the negotiating table
and listen to some of turkey's concerns
not respond to all of them but some of
them so that turkey doesn't feel that it
has to use force or are we so terrified
of air Dogen do we believe that air
began because he lost Istanbul he might
lose the elections that are coming in
the next elections so let's be patient
our dog and we'll shout for a while
he'll try to use force but in the end
he'll lose and then we'll have a more
insular turkey once again we'll have the
likes of imam or glue and chp and that
insular turkey will make sure that
turkey no longer exerts itself on the
foreign policy this is the gamble that
Greece Israel and Egypt are having they
are gambling that aragon would lose the
next election so there is no need to
listen to him okay this is why we see
Turkey flexing its muscle this is why
you see Turkey insisting that it has to
get involved in Libya ok I'm sorry to
cut you off there Sammy handsy but we
are out of time great to get your
thoughts and thank you very much indeed
for joining us there from London